Einer gigantischen Kollision unsere Milchstraße
sind Forschende jetzt auf die Spur gekommen. Eine
äußerst geheimnisvolle Kraken-Galaxie hat die
Entwicklung unserer Milchstraße entscheidend
geprägt. Ein internationales Forschungsteam
hat das mit Hilfe von künstlicher Intelligenz
entdeckt. Herausgekommen ist dabei eine echte
Premiere: Der erste vollständig rekonstruierte
Stammbaum unserer Heimatgalaxie. Alle Infos zu den
gewaltigen und mysteriösen Kollisions-Ereignissen
unserer Milchstraße bekommt ihr jetzt bei
Clixoom Science & Future - aktiviert die
Glocke und abonniert den Kanal, nur
so verpasst ihr nichts. Los gehts!
Herzlich willkommen! Ihr Durchmesser beträgt
unglaubliche 100.000 Lichtjahre, sie setzt sich
aus bis zu 200 Milliarden Sternen zusammen und
nicht zuletzt ist sie auch unsere galaktische
Heimat: Die Milchstraße, die Galaxie also, in
der wir leben. Dennoch haben Fachleute sie noch
längst nicht im Detail verstanden und viele
Fragen sind noch offen. Eine der wohl größten
Herausforderungen der Astronomie: Den Stammbaum
unserer Milchstraße zu rekonstruieren. Wie ist
sie über die Jahrmilliarden entstanden? Und genau
DAS ist jetzt einem internationalen Forschungsteam
gelungen. Mit dabei waren auch Astonominnen
und Astronomen der Universität Heidelberg.
Klar ist schon seit längerer Zeit, dass in der
Milchstraßen-Vergangenheit wirklich dramatische
Veränderungen stattgefunden haben müssen. Die
neuen Ergebnisse aus Heidelberg und den USA aber
offenbaren eine bisher unbekannte spektakuläre
Kollision mit einer mysteriösen Kraken-Galaxie.
Und dieses Ereignis hat die Milchstraße wohl
nachhaltig geprägt. Also wie spürt man Milliarden
Jahren danach eine Kollision auf? Astronomie-Teams
konnten bereits in verschiedenen Modellen zeigen,
dass vor allem das Verschmelzen eine große Rolle
bei der Entwicklung von Galaxien spielt. Denn
durch Verschmelzungsprozesse gelangen Galaxien
nach Ansicht der Wissenschaft über Milliarden von
Jahren an ihre Hauptmassen. Eine super chaotische
Vergangenheit also, die auch unsere Milchstraße
durchlebt hat. Doch wie genau sah diese aus? Wie
genau können wir uns die Verschmelzungs-Geschichte
unsere Milchstraße vorstellen? Hat unsere
Milchstraße über Milliarden Jahre hinweg
mehrere große Galaxien geschluckt und ist dadurch
zu ihrer Größe gewachsen? Auf diese bislang
ungeklärten Fragen gibt es jetzt erste Antworten.
Für das Forschungsteam um den Heidelberger
Astronom Diederik Kruijssen und seinem britischen
Kollegen Joel Pfeffer waren dafür vor allem die
sogenannten Kugelsternhaufen von großer Bedeutung.
Diese Kugelsternhaufen hatten die Milchstraße
einst in einer großen Anzahl umgeben -
möglicherweise könnten es sogar tausende
gewesen sein. Doch dann stürzten sie ineinander
oder wurden von der Milchstraße verschluckt und
aufgesogen. Etwa 150 Kugelsternhaufen kommen
heutzutage noch überall in der Milchstraße
vor. Vor allem aber sind sie im sogenannten
galaktischen Halo zu finden. Dieser umhüllt
quasi unsere Milchstraße. Charakteristisch für
Kugelsternhaufen ist die wirklich hohe Sterndichte
und, dass sich die Sterne im Inneren des Zentrums
extrem verdichten. Hier lassen sich nicht mal mit
den leistungsstärksten Teleskopen überhaupt
einzelne Sterne ausmachen. Im Kugelsternhaufen
ist die Sterndichte übrigens - ACHTUNG - 20.000
Mal höher als bei unserer Sonne. Dazu der Astronom
Diederik Kruijssen von der Universität Heidelberg:
“Viele von ihnen stammen aus kleineren Galaxien,
die einst zu unserer Heimatgalaxie verschmolzen
sind". Andere der Haufen entstanden wohl
möglicherweise auch innerhalb der Milchstraße.
Ein wirklich spannendes Funfact dabei: Die Sterne,
die dieses ganze “Chaos” überlebt haben, sind
nicht nur älter als jedes Fossil auf der Erde,
sondern auch deutlich älter als unsere
Sonne. Fachleute gehen davon aus,
dass ihr Ursprung tatsächlich zurück reicht
bis an die Anfangs-Tage des Universums selbst.
Die Analyse der Kugelsternhaufen brachte
das internationale Forschungsteam bei vielen
der bislang ungeklärten Forschungsfragen
weiter. Spannend waren dabei vor allem die
chemische Zusammensetzung, das Alter und die
Orbitalbewegung der Kugelsternhaufen. Diese
Ergebnisse mussten dann mit den Eigenschaften
der Vorläufergalaxien zusammengebracht werden,
in denen sie sich einst gebildet hatten. Denn sie
behalten viele der charakteristischen Merkmal aus
ihrer Muttergalaxie und sind so leicht zuzuordnen.
Auch wenn die Kollision mehr als zehn Milliarden
Jahre her ist! Eine super komplexe und spannende
Aufgabe! Denn wenn zwei Galaxien miteinander
verschmelzen, wirbeln deren Kugelsternhaufen
quasi einfach durcheinander. Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler waren bislang daran
verzweifelt. Denn das Bestimmen davon,
welche Haufen in der Vergangenheit mal gemeinsam
eine eigene Galaxie gebildet hatten gestaltete
sich bislang als fast unmöglich. Bislang konnten
aufgrunddessen lediglich vier frühere Galaxien
identifiziert und bestimmt werden, die
mit der Milchstraße verschmolzen sind.
Dazu der Astronom Diederik Kruijssen:
“Die größte Herausforderung war, dass die
Bahnbewegungen der Kugelsternhaufen beim
Verschmelzungsprozess in extrem chaotischer
Art und Weise verändert werden".
Um diese Komplexität zu überwinden,
haben wir ein neuronales Netzwerk entwickelt und
mithilfe unserer E-MOSAICS-Simulationen trainiert.
Wir waren erstaunt, wie genau die Künstliche
Intelligenz (KI) die Verschmelzungsprozesse der
von uns simulierten Galaxien nur anhand ihrer
Kugelsternhaufen rekonstruieren konnte." Die
Künstliche Intelligenz half den Fachleute außerdem
dabei, die Charakteristika und Eigenschaften der
Kugelsternhaufen in der Milchstraße näher
zu analysieren. So konnten beispielsweise
die stellaren Massen und zudem sogar auch die
Verschmelzungszeiten der Vorläufer-Galaxien
bestimmt werden - und das mit einer hohen
Präzision. Und die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler kamen zu einem weiteren
spektakulären Ergebnis. Denn bei ihrer
Analyse entdeckten sie eine Kollision zwischen
der Milchstraße und einer bislang unbekannten
Galaxie. Eine äußerst mysteriöse Galaxie. Diese
Galaxie, die von der Fachwelt jetzt als “Krake”
bezeichnet wird, muss vor elf Milliarden Jahren
mit unserer Milchstraße kollidiert sein. Ein
super prägendes Ereignis für unsere Heimatgalaxie
, wie der Wissenschaftler Diederik Kruijssen sagt:
“Die Kollision mit der Kraken-Galaxie muss
das bedeutendste Ereignis gewesen sein,
das die Milchstraße je erlebt hat (...). Daher
muss diese Kollision das Aussehen unserer
Heimatgalaxie nachhaltig verändert haben“. Der
Astronom bezieht sich dabei auf die Tatsache, dass
die Milchstraße vor elf Milliarden Jahren viermal
weniger Masse besessen hatte als heutzutage. Ein
enorm großes und spektakuläre Kollisions-Ereignis,
auf das das internationale Forschungsteam da nun
gestoßen ist. Deutlich enormer noch einmal als
der Zusammenstoß mit der Gaia-Enceladus-Galaxie,
vor etwa neun Milliarden Jahren. Dieses
Ereignis hatten Fachleute BISLANG als das größte
Kollisions-Ereignis gehalten. Ein Trugschluss, wie
die aktuelle Studie aus Heidelberg nun zeigt.
Klar ist aber: Die aktuelle Studie schafft
es zum ersten Mal, einen vollständigen
Familienstammbaum unserer Heimatgalaxie zu
erstellen. Das internationale Forschungsteam
geht den neuen Ergebnisse zufolge davon
aus, dass sich die Milchstraße im Laufe
ihrer Geschichte mit insgesamt fünf Galaxien
vereinigt hat. In ihnen waren wohl mehr als
100 Millionen Sterne versammelt. Doch nicht nur
das: Hinzu kommen etwa zehn weitere Galaxien,
die mindestens zehn Millionen Sterne in sich
trugen. Die massereichsten Vorläufer-Galaxien
sind der aktuellen Analyse wohl vor sechs
bis elf Milliarden Jahren mit der MIlchstraße
kollidiert. Doch wie können die Überreste dieser
Vorläufer-Galaxien aufgespürt werden? Genau
dabei könnten die Ergebnisse der Heidelberger
Studie beitragen - davon sind die beteiligten
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
überzeugt. Dazu Diederik Kruijssen “Bei
mehr als fünf von ihnen ist dies bereits gelungen.
Mit den bestehenden und mit künftigen Teleskopen
sollte es möglich sein, sie alle zu finden".
Doch nicht nur der Blick in die Vergangenheit
der Milchstraße, unserer Heimatgalaxie, ist super
spannend. Auch ein Blick in die Zukunft lohnt
sich. Und hier gleich vorweg: Das Motto, Fressen
und Gefressen werden, wird sich hier wohl nicht
ändern. Und so gehen Forschungsteams fest davon
aus, dass die Milchstraße nicht ewig existieren
wird: In etwa vier Milliarden Jahren wird sie
nämlich mit der Andromedagalaxie, ihrem Nachbarn,
zusammenstoßen. Gerade kommen sich die beiden
Galaxien immer näher - und das ziemlich schnell.
Mit etwa 400.0000 km/h rasen sie aufeinander zu.
Und die Kollision hat bereits begonnen! Dazu gibt
es in den nächsten Tagen ein extra Video.
Dafür einfach Clixoom abonnieren. Das geht
hier und hier geht es weiter mit Das Zentrum
unserer Galaxie entzündet sich! Anklicken,
anschauen und eben Clixoom Science &
Future abonnieren! Bis dann, bleibt dran!